no man can fully grasp how far and how  fast we have come there is no strife no  prejudice no national conflict in outer  space as yet its hazards a hostile to us  all its conquest deserves the best of  all mankind and its opportunity for  peaceful cooperation may never come  again soon the missions primary goal has  been achieved looking at a large single  cell biological but ain't it on the gun  but I think it's time we're looking at  the first proof of life beyond Earth you  finally a daddy it's gonna be a big  custody battle over this one that's  beautiful you  we set sail we ask God's blessing  the most hazardous and dangerous and  greatest adventure on which man has ever  embarked this nation will continue to be  a pioneer in the new frontier space  you